[Music]
I'm gay
you what I'm gay
I've always been gay mama does not look
happy in the master of none she co-wrote
the episode loosely based on her life it
won her an Emmy for comedy writing
making weaith the first black woman to
receive the honor did it really happen
like that Lena with your mom yeah yeah
she was not a happy camper
at first but then you know over time
yeah all things settled and she still
loves you still loves me still loves you
so Lena also wrote the new movie queen
and slim it follows a black couple who's
on their very first date who
accidentally killed a white police
officer in self-defense during a traffic
stop where are you going to find
somebody with a phone so I can call my
family you're a black man that killed a
cop and took his gun I'm not a criminal
you are now now Lina waits joins us at
the table I want to get the back story
of how this came about cuz you were
having a conversation with James Frey
best-selling author mm-hmm he planted
this little seed for you about this
movie I mean he did he came up to me at
a party and he said hey I have an idea
for a movie that I can't write and he's
like it's a black man black woman on a
first date on their way home police
officer pulls them all very good things
escalate very quickly and they kill him
a self defense yeah and I said and then
they decide to just get in the car and
go and I was like you're right you can't
write that [ __ ] but I can't I can't you
just don't call it a Bonnie and Clyde
story because you're go to you would
think as Bonnie and Clyde
not this time no and I did revisit that
film before I started writing and Thelma
Louise as well but I think almost the
things that I wanted to sort of break
those rules and break convention that's
but people of color in the center of a
narrative and that you know we are in a
war that we didn't start right and I
feel like black people when they walk
out their door they go to war every day
yeah they have to decide what black
person do I want to show up as this
morning do I want to be MLK don't want
to be Michael Mayer people know you as a
performer but you think of yourself at
heart as a writer I'm definitely a
writer first yeah so when you when
someone drops in something like this in
your lap what do you do I am
immediately my wheels started spinning
and I just thought if to black people
killed a police officer they would
instantly become heroes yeah I think
because of the relationship that black
people have had with police officers
over the course of time but I don't I
don't think of black people thing they
would become heroes you said I thought
so
that's just instantly sort of that's
what I thought I was like if if I heard
a story about that I would wonder like
oh man what was that what was that about
like why would they do that and that's
the thing like we as particularly I
think black people have to create the
heroes that we need and I think that
because when I was a young person and I
would see police officers and during the
civil rights movement they would be
holding people down and every guns and
batons and so for me when when you're in
school and they say the police officer
is your friend as a young black person I
don't know that's not really my
experience you say yeah what do you hope
people take away from this stuff you
know whatever they bring to it I think
as an artist I don't know if it's my job
to give people answers it's my job to
ask questions and to show us ourselves
so that way we can sort of come to terms
with who we are as a society your your
director and someone you've worked with
before on the master of none show milena
mat-su cos she has called us a protest
film yeah is that something you would
use as well I mean I think of it as
protest art I know Nina Simone said it
is an artist duty to reflect the times
and I believe that I'm doing that I'm
reflecting the times in which we live I
do believe it's open season on black
bodies and when I look at the news every
day and hear you guys tell stories about
black unarmed people that have been
killed by police officers unfortunate no
absolutely and then a week later you
report that the police officer is back
on the force it's very traumatizing it's
very traumatizing for me every time I
see that I think for some people is just
a news story but whenever I see a name
come across the screen a part of me dies
you said there's a black artist you take
tragedies and make them beautiful mmm
yeah I don't think we have a choice we I
think black people have been making
beauty out of misery for decades
and I think that's our superpower you're
not calling this an anti cop film are
you know yeah because if when people see
the film they'll see that just like
black people on a monolith neither are
police you know and it's all very
layered but I do think that when black
people see that police uniform it
represents something
that can be scary that can be dangerous
and it could be the end of your life
you also call is it's a first for you
writing yeah the first for Molina
directing and it's a first for the lead
actress yeah were you scared to have so
many first on one project for something
that's so big you know I wasn't scared I
think I believed in us and I believed in
our ability to tell this story in our
native tongue you know always say that
black people have a broken English to a
little bit of yeah a little bit of City
and a little dash of slavery oh my gosh
lean away thank you so much Queen and
slim is in theaters November 27th